Kylie Jenner and rumored boyfriend  Travis Scott get matching tattoos I hope  the person I'm dating successes me  [Music]  the 19 year olds Keeping Up with the  Kardashians star and the rapper appear  to have his and her butterfly tats the  couple shared photos of their new ink on  snapchat Monday  Kylie's tiny tat is on the back of her  right ankle while Travis is on the left  the 25 year old has a new single out  titled butterfly effect which many  speculate is about his relationship with  the reality star I don't want to look  back and regret not being a teenager the  two first sparked romance rumours in  April when they were spotted hanging out  at Coachella since then they've been  seen packing on the PDA  I'm just really living my life  [Music]  you